[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dude i remember one time i was driving
naked around town right because this is
back when people didn't know if you were
naked you know
and
the cop there was a cop and pulled
somebody else over right
this is back when people didn't know
whether or not you were naked yeah now
everybody tells everybody they're like
oh you know they'll make a funny video
or something back in the day you could
drive with no pants on yeah or no shirt
nothing and they're like oh he's got a
shirt off it's hot out you just feel
like
yeah now you'd be like this guy's
[ __ ] naked
yeah yeah slow ride nice but now it's
like you can just dig in here back then
you would just cruise around naked pull
up talk to people in their yard and [ __ ]
their [ __ ] they have no idea why
because it was
it was fun jay
i don't disagree it was free
entertainment was there any fear of
getting caught
no i don't you keep telling the story
because you're too good a storyteller
for me to be you know that's back when
it was the wild west dude you know you
could just hey how are you guys do you
guys just move in here and it's some
lady [ __ ] you know cutting her kid's
hair in the yard and you're just sitting
there [ __ ] butt naked bruh um would
she ever see that you were naked or no
they thought you were just a paint just
a local neighbor
that was nice you're a citizen you were
a citizen yeah you're a local citizen
dude you make a naked one yeah you were
one of the you were one of the many
citizens
that did that hit puberty locally and
you were [ __ ] living it up just
driving around town you know pulled into
the driveway and an owl took off it was
big too it's gross i think owls the meat
the uh oh you ate them you're saying
yeah but the you guys ate owls yeah i
think that's legal you probably
shouldn't say that on the podcast
well
i didn't have a lot
billboard used to have a joke about it i
didn't have a lot man i had no i think i
even spit it out i'm not even joking
bill clinton when you smoke that weed
and they had two they didn't have all
the things they don't have a lot of meat
on them
i [ __ ] don't like owls
they're predators they're important yeah
you don't have rats everywhere yeah but
you know they're i think they're violent
then they're dirty and they they get
this
owls whoever did their pr you notice
everybody thinks they're smart and they
can read and they're like yeah they had
a good pr yeah right yeah look at that
we only got one up jimmy
but see how much little meat is on him
you think there's more
you know the spoon you all have that as
a bowl on the end it's kind of [ __ ]
cheating honestly but you know what
what do you mean just the really deep
ones yes i do just oh you mean for the
soup yeah for whatever yeah they're soup
[ __ ] spoons bro
is that a bowl whatever you want to do
whatever you want to do all right yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
it's a spoon yeah yeah whatever dude
these [ __ ] little pinoy ladles you
know
yeah yeah
okay dude
things you scoop up all your [ __ ]
yeah how is nashville i've i've heard
great things about nashville it's good
man it's pretty cool last uh last winter
it snowed and so we everybody went out
to like the capital and was like just
like smiling down the stairs just
sending it dude it's pretty sick because
it probably it probably doesn't snow off
no it smells about every seven years so
like people are out there people are
fired up people are out there yelling
jesus christ and stuff and just fired up
oh yeah jesus christ
we love you god
that guy's funny to see you in the bible
bro
you know some people might say i'm like
peter
i could see you in there coming in on a
[ __ ] little boat yeah that's awesome
so funny because that's how my parents
got here
you know
no but i'll sing it with you uh it just
reminds me of like a romance song
so yeah go to a party
oh yeah yeah i know that song yeah yeah
but i don't know any of the words after
that
everyone stop as this
yeah you're saying that like you're deaf
i like it
yeah i think we're alone now oh yeah
yeah oh that song will make you just be
erect i remember being on the school bus
so [ __ ] erect bro
dude i remember that [ __ ] bruh dude i
love being erect when i was young man
now it's whatever now it's whatever now
it's like [ __ ] i have to do something
now what do you know what does my dick
need me to do right it's like eating now
yeah so
i'll tell you this if you want to feed a
family of four
you can't just have one owl i will say
that though
when i was in uh
school some type of school i would go to
the library and look at all of the
that was all my pornography is what i
would look at it was that kind of stuff
heavily bro i remember going in there
and i wouldn't get it going again well i
would get erect and then i would put my
erection into the book where
in the library right like up near the
shelves and close it as hard as i could
on my penis so you were like tributing
renaissance paintings i was yeah i mean
i was into like and i remember i'd go to
the certain section and be back there it
was dicey it's crazy i never really
thought about that i went through this
whole
little deal to do that that's a lot it
is a lot that's a lot it's crazy you did
that it is crazy you're sticking your
book dick in books and smash it not
putting them in i would open the book i
like the book
i'm not saying the book was asking for
it but i'm saying yes
but i would do that man i would just
like uh
the book was willing to be able to
totally like seven years i was probably
13 maybe 12. this feels like a 7th grade
yeah endeavor just something yeah i
think it was just like
i think i just wanted to i don't know if
i wanted to meet a woman from the past
or if i
[Laughter]
was just that's how i could see
pornography
you wanted a woman from the past do you
think maybe i don't know i'm just trying
to think of why would i have done that
because you know dick it feels good to
smash your dick into things yeah that
too and they were naked ladies
yeah
porn back then was
impossible and if you could score some
porn in school
yeah that's
dude i would look at like the science
book yeah i'd be like a skinless woman
and i'd be like nice yeah like you see
your [ __ ] you can see the inside of
her see the workings
dude so you just made you into the drugs
oh bro give me this biology book oh a
little anatomy i remember two moons and
eclipse and i remember thinking it was
like breasts and drawings
yeah
oh yeah it's [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah
you ever save a life
um
yeah i think so man some guy
uh
wait or did i almost maybe i think i
almost drowned that's what happened
other so yeah i was almost a victim i
almost drank well did you save your own
life no i didn't a man save a dude a
[ __ ] dude bro this topless guy jumps
in right i did not even want him to save
me the second i saw the dude who saved
me i was [ __ ] so important what did
you mean topless guy was it a lifeguard
he was a guy at a beach he was at the
beach but
the way he was built he just looked he
had no time
it was a lot longer
for you to confuse the fact that you
saved somebody's life 40 seconds man
me and my sister were under there
and many years later i remember him
coming back to our household drunk one
night and saying i saved y'all [ __ ]
saved y'all
we're like why
i
yeah
how'd that go
who were you trying to summon
i mean some of the people that showed up
there was one guy who showed up i
remember who uh all his some guy showed
up whose car had been like attacked he'd
been at a bar and people kicked all the
windows out of his
uh
car so we didn't get anybody we wanted
to be there but
that guy was like looking for help or
whatever right we happened to be doing a
seance you know we had uh just happened
to be yeah we and that dude [ __ ] like
is banging on the door we're like
who ordered this guy
this dude just got jumped this dude's
bad luck and elon
put this tweet tweet out
gonna put an old-school drive-in roller
skates and rock and roll and rock
restaurant at one of the new special
supercharger locations in la
i don't even know what that means yeah
elon's turning into the [ __ ] white
levar ball
sometimes i feel like he's not even
doing any of that [ __ ] that he says
yeah well some of it sounds absolutely
impossible to do he's like we're gonna
gonna go to mars dude
you can't even drive through memphis
safely okay
and also who would be better who better
to do relationship advice than somebody
that's trans somebody that has a
relationship going on inside of their
body i was gonna say that that she sees
both sides she comes out from both sides
dude why are we not using trans people
to help us
do
marital advice and support because they
are a man and a woman they
nobody could sort it out at once than
the original recipe we had this one guy
he used to give us
maybe four dollars or something
and he made it to look in his ass but
he'd walk about like 20 feet off and
hold his ass open
as long as we looked we got the money
so just [ __ ]
who made sure you looked how could how
could he who made sure you got paid
that's what i want to know he gave the
money first okay got you got your
pleasure because that'll be a shitty
deal at a certain point you were you
were kind of grandfathered in if he knew
you were gonna look you kind of got the
money your grandfather did
well we live by a rest area dude a lot
of like gay men would meet up back there
and make out you know
and so you see a lot of drug you know a
lot of men on drugs back there so see
this is what i was talking about all
this is really interesting to me i
didn't have i didn't have four dollar
ass show guy
i didn't have the the the drug addict
but you just not remember it though that
that's sometimes something that i wonder
what people look at is do people
remember it that's a weird thing is i
think because even some of my best
friends i'm like dude do you remember
this and they'll be like i don't
remember that i'm like what bro how do
you not remember it's like that's the
only thing that happened to us you know
that's it how do you not remember it
you work at the holiday inn express like
down the street is one of the only
things that happened you know
you've got to remember that man
so i think some of it's just about
remembering stuff you know you're
actually right i feel like i kind of
would remember if somebody handed me
four dollar bills to look at their
[ __ ]
yeah yeah i think that'd be something i
never yeah yeah yeah but like but like
came out you go i'm going to piss in
your bushes you did kill my fur in the
last the last time you did yeah you
killed one of our friends
they would serve this at a hospital [ __ ]
is healthy bro okay yeah
and then you said like um can i i'm
gonna go pee outside i go the bathroom's
right here you gotta know i want to pee
outside you prefer peeing outside dude i
remember when i was a child man i was so
scared i remember this as a kid like i
would get so scared at night that
i would pee i remember hearing that
wolves like if they had wolves in your
area
that they if you peed then they wouldn't
come around the urine because the wolves
would mark their area
yeah yeah yeah you know what i'm talking
about wolves in louisiana huh
we had two wolves actually dude and some
man unleashed him on the uh like in an
air i this is a different story but i'll
tell one story at a time
but at night i would be so scared after
i heard that i would stand on my bed and
literally pee or from the wall all the
way around my bed to the other wall
oh wow definitely come get me at night
that's how scary that's smart though
i thought it was pretty smart dude i saw
evander holyfield the chicago airport
another roommate yeah vander holyfield
yeah right out of college wow where'd
you guys go to college at syracuse no we
went to syracuse community college oh
yeah yeah but it was an ivy league
community college oh yeah so it was one
of the best community colleges ever i
went to a poison ivy league school you
did yeah oh man [ __ ] itching to get
out of there
that's pretty bad take a break we'll be
right back yeah
that was pretty bad
real quick make sure you check out joke
world on instagram the link is in the
bio we're sending everyone some free
stickers when you do we got the joke
world logo the what's the deal with
airplane peanuts sticker that's new
featuring a new comedian on our
instagram every day and more clips like
these we build up a pretty big group of
like-minded comedy fans here on youtube
even if we could get like half of that
over to instagram where we're featuring
these up-and-coming comedians that would
be awesome to give them a big platform
to share their jokes on maybe you'll
like some of them maybe you won't have
fun with it so make sure you check us
out get your free stickers link in bio
back to the video
i would pee around the bed i remember to
keep the wolves out yeah yeah but then
like this there was it literally got all
starchy on the carpet over time ah cause
i peed for years i feel probably four
years outside of my bed yeah and i
remember i would stack my underpants
full of um
like towels and t-shirts because i was
so scared i didn't want to get up and go
to the bathroom because i thought
something was gonna get me so i'm like
if i pee i gotta like make it so i don't
have to change my bed and stuff so i
could go back to sleep yeah so i just
remember man i would just stack my
underpants just full of like shirts i
was never gonna wear maybe gonna where i
put those further out
so that the
so the p would hit like the ones i'm
never gonna wear first yeah ah
and then like the better clothes on the
outside your mama never said anything
like god smells weird in here i'm sure
she i'm sure she thought that yeah yeah
but there was just i think bigger fish
to fry yeah you know no offense
no i mean i love fish and i like crying
man i'm not no none taken bro well i
will say you are the catch of the day
i'll say that by the way hey bro i'm
right here dude
and you are pretty good good you're a
great man hey thank you so much we had a
question what is this one sean
hi theo
my name is joe and i'm a big fan from
little old england enjoying my bath
and i have a question for shane
um what is his opinion on age gap
relationships
um still seems to be okay younger woman
and the older guy but not so much the
other way around so um look forward to
hearing your opinions
wow
that could be one of that's somebody's
school teacher
she's in the bathroom it's a british
asmr in a bathtub
she's asking me about how i feel about
older women yeah would you bring me down
here to make me come dude no you trying
to get me hard was this a setup no i've
never seen a setup huh no you invite me
over here you put on some asmr give me
[ __ ]
rock hard give me some
you water off on this podcast
what's that what does she want i'm not
looking at the question no we yes how do
i feel about older ladies i've never
i've never seen that question i've never
seen that woman i'm glad she's staying
clean i don't know that lady um she's
attractive obviously i think she's
trying to look at the suds on her chest
a little i didn't notice that before
but no we didn't bring you down here to
get anything out of you man
at all i mean just have some information
i guess
what have you just masturbated under the
mic and just left
her questions what is he uh i don't [ __ ]
anybody out of a like an urgent care or
not you won't do it no
yeah i don't do it man my sister works
at him i've seen yeah some behind the
scenes i'm not doing that [ __ ] have you
ever seen it oh yeah well i've seen
poker before on television well they do
it on there it's called element of
disguise ah
so i don't know what your eyes are doing
right what are you learning i might not
even have my i think my eyes could have
been left in the car
i could be in the car reading a book
right now okay
wait do you have a good poker face no
that's the thing it's like you know i
wanna have a good pokey face look at
that
pokemon
just come out i remember my stepdad is
yelling at me in the yard one time told
you to come out yeah i was like i'm not
[ __ ] gay bro i was like i'm just not
flying some girl home that i just met
you know just to prove to you guys i
catch you i thought he could catch it
alive
yeah he thought maybe he was gonna leave
a uh
yeah like he's gonna set a trap yeah
he's gonna set a trap yeah he's setting
a trap yeah he's like a slick boxer
[Laughter]
he said the trump boy you
just come out of the closet boy like
what the [ __ ] my stepdad found out that
some lady was getting married that he
used to have a huge crush on
and he went over he was at a bar or
something that night he found out she's
got engaged and he drove over to the
house
and went up on her porch like in the
middle of the night wow and said look i
got all these feelings for you and blah
blah blah and she didn't care right and
while he was up there somebody burned
his car in the [ __ ] street
so he was there and literally his car is
burning which is a horrible look if
you're trying to tell somebody like that
you're the guy for them right now it's
just like
my car and then you come back with a
bicycle yeah
no way dude you're not that guy your car
set on fire you're a black widow joke
whether or not we ever know each other
at the end of our lives will make me
smile
at the very end of my life because it's
the one of the funniest
simply well-written jokes that i've ever
heard that's i'm just giving you a
compliment and that's it to end the show
thanks man yeah my buddy got bit by a
black widow dude yeah she was in her 40s
outside of a bus stop dude yeah
dude it's so funny say that sometimes i
don't even feel funny sometimes anymore
that it makes my heart
every time i hear about the guy today
was by by the house today he goes up
black widows the uh the the male dude
you know black widows out by that garage
i seen i go i know and i hear black
widow and i immediately think of you
saying my buddy got blood by black widow
she was in her 40s who's at a bus stop
she was angry for no reason that's what
it used to say she was angry for no
reason why was it going to school in
louisiana for what for
liberal arts urban planning i'm urban
planner
you're trying to like grow [ __ ] weed or
something what do you plan to do no no
we just we design neighborhoods dude in
neighborhoods are you being serious yeah
i'm urban planner like you if there was
a sore system that needed to be put into
place under a playground you'd be the
guy guy for the job or i wouldn't do
that i could handle like where the like
what the route the mailman should take
and like all kind of zone like basically
but you never think about that [ __ ] yeah
no i know you never thought the urban
planner
yeah please can you [ __ ] time stamp
that high five and take it out
dude people will repent if they like
children will repent to say all the
sledding in nashville will stop it will
come to a [ __ ] call
of male seed people see that high five
man i'll double it no i'll match it i'll
match it right watch watch i'll match it
is that good
you know what i just did there i'll do a
turn right yeah i'll look at the guy
match it okay
ooh
okay then i'm gonna do this
you do that you do that
yeah yeah yeah
oh you're the tongue that you do the
tongue thing
yeah
oh man
all in bro
all in right or he's holding a butt
right all in right and i'll do a little
giggle
like i can't believe it okay
no
no do it
oh that's kind of confident
and i look around and i look in the
camera right yeah like there's a camera
there because espn i'll go like this
right yeah and you go like and then i
with looking in the camera okay i push
it all in like this okay right and then
what do you do
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i look over at the camera
yeah yeah
because i have five aces
five [ __ ]
five
[ __ ] and i go
all the way right so she set the alarm
at 7am oh an alarm here's my thing alarm
makes my dick soft really yeah so i have
to like
i just like any like alerts or anything
that's right you know i can't do it if
there's broken glass in the room can't
do it can't do it even just a little bit
ago i went and got this smoothie you
know and i used to work at a smoothie
shop actually but
i went and got this smoothie you know
because i taste other people's work yeah
and uh
the
the parking spot when i pull in
it just it's one of those it's like a la
spot it's like there's no
you try to get out it couldn't get out
so then i had to go and park down
further it's just like there's a real
spot but it's just people parking can't
get out of their cars super compact yeah
just that kind of just little things
where everything is just a hassle yeah
you know so when you see somebody
finally take their life you're like oh
yeah
relief yeah that guy that got shot for
smoothies in the same place
are you gonna send me something or what
let's keep in mind that i open all the
mail so it's gotta be something
oh
well have you heard that justin
timberlake song what is it
what's wrong there's so many dude the
one with the uh it's like mail they sent
it's like a um dick in the box oh is
that it no
this guy dude
this guy
i would never send that and that is a
joke interesting thing you just
shouldn't laugh either okay yeah mark
[ __ ] white berg over there this dude
is freaking
one of owen benjamin's henchmen yeah
yeah okay i don't know i don't know what
was going on in the area you know we had
a lot of stray animals by us really you
know rabies was big so you had like a
lot of fear in the air
um
i'm trying to think of what else was
really popping off you know the bus this
dude uh
used to do slip and falls at pizza
that's how you
make money insurance camps yeah yeah we
grew up during like the height of that
like everybody was doing you know this
is before it you know
yeah this is like prank videos but it
was real you know they were doing
insurance money for it you know a lot of
people falling down in pizza hut we had
a guy bus and he was working the circuit
one year doing the slip and falls
and he died he broke his head open on a
salad bar
and sarah
business cost of doing business and want
to play that game yeah and it was like
and we all had to be at the funeral and
[ __ ] dude and
so um theo vaughn oh you little spiked
skull hey [ __ ] you
hey bro hey bro don't call me that you
want to bring a swordfish to a gunfight
you little piss guppy
don't say that
i'm a piss cop you sent me those dirty
dishes and you sent the snake bubba
first of all i don't know where where
the [ __ ] you live in nashville number
two it's like why would i if i was gonna
were they poisonous the snakes
the snake was a rat snake bub right bub
can they kill you bob huh can they kill
you bob they can't kill me
why huh you only send one
right right if you want to kill me
you need to say mas
the best thing a scientist can do is a
real honest-to-goodness breakthrough
would you have sex with a scientist you
think
yeah like a movie scientist like she
keeps the glasses on yeah they're always
blonde in the movies right side no
sometimes the dark black hair too
mysterious i bet they're clean too if
you [ __ ] a scientist yeah i bet they
have a clean apartment
maybe but maybe not maybe their [ __ ]
brain is like that chalkboard with all
the squiggly alien mathematics on it
that's true huh yeah yeah what if they
have a bunch of [ __ ] tattoo there's a
bunch of dirty math tattooed around
their puss but how do you get the
ejaculation past the urine
it just just will man
wow just pure will i believed it could
happen
[Music]
you